شكرا لك محمد اذا بالفعل مشاهدينا الكرام
مستمرون معكم في تغطيه وقائع هذه التطورات
في قطاع غزه اسرائيل شنت سلسله غارات اذا
على القطاع خلال هذه الليله حسب مصادر
فلسطينيه اذا واسرائيليه واستهدفت عده
اهداف في قطاع غزه في عقاب اطلاق صواريخ
من لبنان في هجوم نسبته اسرائيل الى
ناشطنا فلسطينيين واقل مصدر امني فلسطيني
ان الطائرات الاسرائيليه شنت سلسله غارات
على مواقع تدريب عده تابعه للكتائب عز
الدين القسام الجناح المسلح لحركه حماس في
مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه
جاءت متزامنه مع انتهاء اجتماعي الحكومه
الامنيه المصغره حيث اتخذت هذه الحكومه
سلسله من القرارات لم تعلن تفاصيلها بعد
فيما قال الرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
ان رد فعل اسرائيل الليله وبعدها سيكلف ما
وصفهم بالاعداء ثمنا باهضا وكان نتنياهو
ذكر ان اسرائيل ستعمل بحزم ضد من يستخدم
العنف مشيرا في الوقت نفسه الى انه ليس
هناك رغبه في تغيير الوضع الراهن للاماكن
المقدسه في القدس
اذا مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في اخر الاخبار
العاجله اذا مراسل العربيه نقل قبل قليل
بان هناك عده صواريخ تم اطلاقها من داخل
قطاع غزه
باتجاه مستوطنات الغلاف حول قطاع غزه
بينما كانت دوره صافرات الانذار في
مستوطنه وطلبه اسرائيل من من سكان هذه
المستوطنات الدخول الى
الملاجئ طبعا في ضوء اذا هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه
اذا مشاهدينا كانت حركه حماس كذلك قالت
انها تحمل اسرائيل مسؤوليه العدوان على
القدس وغزه ودعت الشعب والفصائل الوحده في
مواجهه مفتوحه اذن مشاهدينا كان هناك كذلك
مصادر للعربيه افادت ايضا باتصالات مصريه
موسعه مع الجانب الامريكي والاسرائيلي
وكذلك الفصائل الفلسطينيه للتهدئه وان مصر
طالبه اسرائيل بضروره عدم استهداف
المدنيين والمدن السكنيه وحسب حسب مصادر
العربيه فان اسرائيل ابلغت الوسطاء ان
التصعيد العسكري متوقف على مدى رد الفصائل
واطلاق الصواريخ فيما ابلغت الفصائل من
جهتها الوسطاء بانها سترد على اي استهداف
لقيادتها او عمليات اغتيال
المشاهدين نعود ونستمع لما قاله رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو قبل قليل
سنعمل بقوه ضد المتطرفين الذين يلجاون
لاستخدام العنف ضدنا وبالنسبه للاستهداف
من الجهه الاخرى سنضرب اعدائنا وسيدفعون
ثمن عدوانيتهم وسيكتشفون كيف سيتوحد الشعب
الاسرائيلي بغض النظر عن كل الخلافات من
اجل الدفاع عن دولتنا وشعبنا
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا المتابعه من قطاع غزه
من هناك معنى الصحفي محمد عوض محمد اهلا
بك معنا من جديد لمن التحق بنا الان في
متابعه هذه التغطيه ما الذي استهدفته
الغارات الاسرائيليه حتى الان في قطاع غزه
محمد عوض هل انت معي
طيب اذا محمد ليس معنا الان ولكن
المشاهدين ايضا في انتظار ان نربط الاتصال
به وبمراسلينا اذا مشاهدينا تشاهدون على
جانبي الشاشه صور مباشره لسما القطاع اذا
هناك هدوء حذر الان في هذه اللحظات بعد
سلسله الغارات قبل قليل التي تتابعونها
على الجانب الاخر من الشاشه كما تتابعون
هذه نتائج الغارات التي استهدفت قطاع غزه
والتي استخدمت فيها اسرائيل طائرات من دون
طيار اذا المقاتلات الاسرائيليه كانت شنت
سلسله غارات المشاهدين على اهداف في قطاع
غزه منتصف هذه الليله حسب مصادر فلسطينيه
واسرائيليه في عقاب اطلاق وابل من
الصواريخ من لبنان في هجوم النسبه اسرائيل
الى ناشطين فلسطينيين مصدر امني فلسطيني
قال ان طائرات الاحتلال شنت سلسله غارات
على مواقع تدريب عده تابعه لكتائب عز
الدين القسام الجناح المسلح لحركه حماس في
مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان اكد في بيان بدئه
تنفيذ سلاحه الجوي غارات على قطاع غزه
اذا معنا الان من القدس الينيسان المحلل
السياسي اهلا بك معنا سيد اليميسان بعد
هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه هل
سيتوقف الرد الاسرائيلي عند هذا الحد
الاسرائيلي يتوقف بشرط واحد عن حتى ان
تحصل اسرائيل على كافه الاهداف
لمنظم لحركه حماس التي هي التي كانت
المبرر والتي قامت بالتحريض حتى ان يتم
كفه
استهداف المواقع والاهداف التي وضعتها
اسرائيل نصبح اعينها ثم تتوقف ولكن اذا
حركه حماس وصلت باطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه
القرى والمدن الاسرائيليه انا لا اعتقد ان
القصف الاسرائيلي يتوقف الى اين يمكن ان
يصل هذا القصف
هذا القاسم مستمر هناك بنك كبير لسلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي ولجيش الاسرائيلي بكل ما
يتعلق
بقطاع غزه واذا رؤساء حركت حماس الذين
يقتبئون الان
يواصلون اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل
انا اعتقد ان اسرائيل تواصل استهداف كل من
يمكن لهناك بنك بنك كبير لاهداف ولكن
هذا ما اردت ان اسالك عنه ايضا قبل قليل
مصادر العربيه تحدثت بان اسرائيل قالت ان
الرد الاسرائيلي
سيكون حسب
رد الفصائل
انا اوتامى
تتصل معي مباشره
نعم تفضل نعم كنت اسالك بان مصادر
اسرائيليه قالت بان الرد سيتوقف على حسب
الرد الفلسطيني كذلك هل ماذا يفهم من هذا
هل
اسرائيل تريد ان لا ان تحتوي الموضوع ان
تحتوي الرد
لا بمعنى انك كما قال قبل قليل
وزير الدفاع وايضا رئيس الوزراء ان حتى
اسرائيل
ذو مغزى من حركه حماس ثم ثم تتوقف في
اسرائيل واذا حركت حماس تواصل اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه باتجاه القرى والمدن
الاسرائيليه اسرائيل تعرف كيف تتعامل مع
حركه حماس وربما مع رؤساء حركات حماس
الذين الان يختبئون في اماكن معينه
واسرائيل تعرف ايضا اين هم يختبئون
واقول واؤكد ان اسرائيل لن تتوقف حتى ان
تجبي الثمن الباهد لحركه حماس التي هي
اصبحت المبرر لكل ما يحدث اذا كان في
لبنان واذا كان في شرق القدس واذا كان في
الحرم القدسي الشريف طيب
سيد ايلي ولكن
الفلسطينيون والفصائل الفلسطينيه تحمل
اسرائيل مسؤوليه هذا التصعيد بالاعتداء
على المصلين في المسجد الاقصى
وانا اتجول في شرق شاليه وانا عندما ارى
اتجول باب العمود ارى قوافل المصلين الذين
يتوجهون الى الحرم القدسي الشريف اولا
هناك مجموعه مجموعه تشغيل لتهديدات حركه
حماس بان اسرائيل تريد المساس بمكانه حرام
القدس الشريف وهذا غير صحيح لانك كما اكده
رئيس الوزراء اليوم قبل اجتماع المجلس
الوزاري المصغر ليس لاسرائيل اينيه
ببساس بمكانه الحرم القدسي الشريف بمؤسس
المصلين ولكن عندما
يعتصمون اكثر من 450 شاب داخل الحرم
القدسي الشريف وبحوزتهم وفرقعات وعصي
وحجار لماذا مصلي ياتي ياتي الحرم القدس
الشريف مع المفرقعات هل هذا الامر لا يدنس
مكان الحرم القدسي الشريف عندما اسرائيل
تحترم الحرم القدسي الشريف ياتي الشباب
ياتي الشباب مع مفرقعات لالقاء المفرقعات
على الجنود وعلى افراد الشرطه نعم طيب
ارجو ان تبقى معنا سيد ايليني نيسان من
القدس معنى الان مخيمر ابو سعده من قطاع
غزه مخيمر اهلا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه من
العربيه
اهلا بكم نعم
[موسيقى]
السيد نيسان من القدس وسالته على تحميل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه لاسرائيل مسؤوليه هذا
التصعيد الاعتداء جنودها على المصلين في
المسجد الاقصى لكنه نفى ذلك وقال ان هؤلاء
المعتصمين في المسجد
اتوا ومعهم يعني مجموعه من المفرقعات كيف
ترد على هذا الكلام
يا سيدي يعني الصور التي
خرجت من باحات المسجد الاقصى وباحات الحرم
الشريف تتحدث عن نفسها او كلنا شاهد قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وعناصر الشرطه
الاسرائيليه وهي تعتدي على النساء وعلى
الرجال داخل المسجد الاقصى
ويعني من المتعارف عليه انه في شهر رمضان
الفضيل يعني يبقى المصلون
يعني خلال صلاه العشاء وبعد صلاه العشاء
في صلاه التراويح وحتى ساعات الاعتكاف
المتاخره ولكن ما شاهدناه وهو عكس
التفاهمات الاسرائيليه مع السلطه
الفلسطينيه بوساطه امريكيه واردنيه ومصريه
التي كانت يعني تبحث عن خفض التصعيد في
شهر رمضان المبارك بانه قوات الاحتلال
قامت بالاعتداء على المصلين واخرجتهم
بالقوه من يعني قبل يومين من من المسجد
الاقصى واعتقل عشرات منهم يعني وكما قلت
يعني الصور التي جاءت من من باحات المسجد
الاقصى كانت تتحدث عن هذا العنف
الاسرائيلي غير المبرر وبالتالي ما يتحدث
عنه يعني وانا سمعت اخر ما قالوا لي نيسان
يعني لم يكن مبررا على الاطلاق بالجانب
قوات الاحتلال وعناصر الشرطه الاسرائيليه
نعم هناك من يرى انه هذا التصعيد
ربما يوضع في اطار ان اسرائيل لديها ازمه
داخليه وبالتالي هي تريد الهرب منها الى
مواجهه الى اي حتى ترى ان هذا التحليل
صحيح
اسرائيل تمور بازمه عميقه وهي الازمه
الاسوا منذ قيام اسرائيل في عام 1948 يعني
من الواضح بان هناك حاله انقسام عميقه في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي بين المتدينين
والعناصر اليمينيه من ناحيه التي تؤيد
الاصلاحات القضائيه وبين اليسار
والوسط الاسرائيلي العلماني الليبرالي
الذي يرفض ما كانت تنوي يعني الحكومه
القيام به من اصلاحات ولكن انا لا اعتقد
بانه اسرائيل كانت
نتنياهو او الائتلاف يريد ان يخرج من
الازمه الداخليه من خلال
التصعيد مع الفلسطينيين بعد تقل ان
المسؤول بالدرجه الاساسيه عن هذا التصعيد
هو ايتاماردن غفير وزير الامن الداخلي
الاسرائيلي الذي يعني باتت عناصر الشرطه
وحرس الحدود في اسرائيل تتبع يعني هذه
الوزاره ومن الواضح يعني ليس
هو من المتطرفين الذين يدعو الى اعاده
بناء الهيكل اليهودي والذي يدعو الى فرد
السياده والسيطره اليهوديه على المسجد
الاقصى ولذلك يعني تقديري انه انه هناك
اشخاص وعناصر متطرفه في هذا الائتلاف
الحاكم هي المسؤولي بالدرج الاساسيه عن
حاله التصعيد اما الحديث عن ان يعني هروب
من الازمه الداخليه لتصعيد يعني عدوان مع
غزه او مع الفلسطينيين لا اعتقد انه هذا
وارد لانه يعني اسرائيل لا تعتقد ان
اسرائيل تريد ان تذهب الى الى تصعيد خلال
الاعياد اليهوديه الان وثانيا يعني هناك
مشاكل تواجهها الحكومه الاسرائيليه مع
المؤسسه الامنيه والمؤسسه العسكريه على
خلفيه ما سمي ابن اصل بالتالي دكتور مخيمر
افهم من كلامك ان اسرائيل لن تذهب بعيدا
في تصعيدها الذي بدا هذه الليله بهذه
الغارات في غزه
هذا ما نسمعه يعني صحيح ان القشطه المواقع
تابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
وكما قال المتحدث باسم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بانه الاستهداف كان لمسار
انفاق من غزه باتجاه المدن والبلدات
الاسرائيليه وحسب ما ما يرد يعني هناك
رسائل غير
ناشره
بالجانب الاسرائيلي للوسطاء واعتقد ان مصر
المقصوده بهذا الموضوع او الوساطه الدوليه
ان تنقل رساله للفلس للمقاومه الفلسطيني
بان اسرائيل ليست معنيه بالذهاب الى حرب
موسعه او تصعيد كبير في الوقت الحاضر ارجو
ان تبقى معنا دكتور مخيمر في هذه التغطيه
ونشير مشاهدينا الى هذا العاجل اذا الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول انه استهدف موقعين لتصنيع
الاسلحه تابعين لحماس في شمالي ووسط غزه
معنا من غزه محمد عوض
الكاتب الصحفي محمد اهلا بك معنا في هذه
التغطيه من العربيه
هل نتحدث عن استهداف محدود اذا
لموقعين فقط في قطاع غزه حتى الان كما
يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي
نعم كما تحدثنا في الرساله السابقه كان
استهداف لموقع البطاله الفلسطينيه الشماله
قطاع غزه تحديدا في بلده بيت حانون
بصاروخين من قبل طائرات
المسيره تم السداد الموقع بصاروخين
تساعدت من الموقع لكن بعد هذا القصف
الهدوء هو سيد الموقف وحاله الترقب
والتخوف ما زالت تسود اوساط المواطنين في
قطاع غزه كما تحدثنا
والهدوء النسبي هو
ما نشاهده الان نشاهد يعني المناطق كبيره
من مدينه غزه
صفاء الفصائل الفلسطينيه لم تطلق صواريخ
منذ ربع ساعه تقريبا او 15 دقيقه وعلى
الجانب الاخر لا يوجد اي قصف
الطائرات الاسرائيلي هل هناك اي معلومات
عامه اسفرت عنه الصواريخ التي اطلقت
باتجاه المستوطنات الغلاف
القادمه هي لحظات ترقب ولحظات يعني الجميع
ينتظر ما ستؤول اليه الساعات القادمه
لربما هناك الوصفات الدوليه والمصريه كما
تحدثنا التي دخلت على الخط بشكل كثيف من
اجل عدم انزلاق الاوضاع وتدهور الاوضاع
الميدانيه
المتوافر من معلومات عن هذه الوساطات خاصه
الوساطه المصريه محمد
تحدثنا مع مصدر
رفيع المستوى في في مصر قال ان مصر تجري
اتصالات الى جانب الامم المتحده مع جميع
الاطراف بما فيها فصاله الفلسطينيه
والجانب الاسرائيلي من اجل وقت التصعيد في
قطاع غزه وعدم انزلاق الاوضاع الى حرب قد
لا يستطيع احد ايقافه كما تحدث المصدر
وقال بانها مصدر تجري اتصالات مع كافه
الاطراف في غزه وخارج غزه وهذا الى ان مصر
تتصل باعضاء المكتب السياسي لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي وحماس في الخارج في لبنان او في
قطر من اجل عدم تصعيد الاوضاع وان يلزم
الجميع الهدوء خاصه
نحن في شهر رمضان المبارك وايام تفصلنا عن
ايام الاعتكاف وعيد الفطر كما حدث في ايار
عام 2021 حينما اندلعت الحرب على قطاع غزه
المتخوفه جدا من اندلاع حرب جديده قبل
احمد حسب المصدر الذي قال بان مصر كسفت
جهودها واتصالاتها منذ اول امس وحين وقع
التصعيد في قطاع غزه بدات
مكثفه مع جميع الاطراف من اجل وقف هذا
التصعيد الذي وقع استعاده المساء هذا
اليوم وهذا ما يترجم على الارض الان
الهدوء كما تحدث الزميل مخيمر ابو سعده
والزملاء قالوا بان الهدوء وسيد الموقف
بالطبع هذا ما يشاهدوه على الارض
الوضع الان هادئ كما نشاهد معكم مشاهدينا
على شاشه العربيه في صور مباشره من غزه
ولكن قبل قليل كان مشتعلا اذا سلسله
المقاتلات الاسرائيليه واستهتفت موقعين
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انهما استهدفا مواقع
عسكريه للفصائل الفلسطينيه شكرا لك محمد
عوض على انضمامك الينا في هذه التغطيه
ومعي الان من الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه مدير مكتب العربيه زياد حلبي
زياد هل هذا الهدوء في غزه ينبئ عن احتواء
الموقف عن احتواء الرد الاسرائيلي ام هو
هدوء ما قبل العاصفه
تستمر الغارات او تتجدد ولكن بطبيعه الحال
يعني
المتوقع هو ان لا تتطور الامور الى حرب
شامله اقله بناء على ما قاله احد وزراء
الحكومه الانديه المصغره في ختام الاجتماع
ان الردود الاسرائيليه هذه الليله سواء
جنوبا او شمالا لن تدخل اسرائيل في حرب
لهذا المعنى هذا يبقى قابلا اساسا
للاحتواء لانه صائب كما راينا منذ البدايه
حتى اطلاق الصواريخ هو بمدن قصير في
المستوطنات القريبه جدا من قطاع غزه
واسرائيل استهدفت منشات وانفاق تحت الارض
عمليا كما كانت تفعل في العاده ربما كثافه
الغارات هي المتغير هذه المره ولكن هذا
كله في اطار القواعد الاشتباك المتعارف
عليها لم تكسر طالما ان الامر كذلك يمكن
ان يتم احتواء الموضوع بما يتصل بالجبه
على لبنان ليس واضحا
نسالك عنه لانه الصواريخ التي اطلقت كان
مصدرها لبنان هل سيكون وفق قواعد الاشتباك
على الاقل زياد هل سيكون هناك ضربات او
غارات على جنوب لبنان
سيكون من الصعب جدا على اسرائيل
استراتيجيا حتى ان لا ترد بشكل او باخر
ولو رمزيا
عمليا على ما حدث من جنوب لبنان رغم انها
اعفت نفسها من مواجهه مع حزب الله منذ
البدايه عندما شددت على ان حماس هي من
اطلق من جنوب لبنان ولهذا الثقل الاساسي
في الرد على ما يبدو هو في قطاع غزه بمعنى
قصفت من الشمال وترد في الجنوب لكن يرى
مراقبون بانها قد يكون نوع من الرد وان
كان رمزيا في الساعات المقبله في جنوب
لبنان بدون كسر قواعد اللعبه ايضا
عدم استهداف اهداف تابعه لحزب الله
واتابع بني تحتيه للدوله اللبنانيه هذا
يبقينا امام اهداف هي ليست اهدافا حقيقه
كما جرى في مرات سابقه اطلاق عشرات
الخدائق في اتجاه مناطق مفتوحه ليس فيها
احد هذا قد نراه في الساعات المقبله وقد
لا نراه على فكره وبالاضافه الى امكانيه
الرد طبعا بالله في سوريا وهذا متبع وغير
مقرف بالنسبه لاسرائيل وتفضله دائما نعم
طيب انت على الحدود
زياد ولكن الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه
اسالك عن المناطق المحاذيه لقطاع غزه
المستوطنات خاصه في مستوطنه مستوطنات
الغلاف اقصد كان هناك حديث عن صواريخ
فلسطينيه تم اطلاقها باتجاهها وتم تفعيل
القبه الحديديه ما المعلومات المتوافره
عما اسفرت عنه هذه الصواريخ
هذا صحيح جدا اطلقت عشره صواريخ على الاقل
تجاه المستوطنات اعترض بعضها خاصه فيروز
وجنوبي عسقلان هناك اصابه واحده
ليست مباشره من صاروخ ولكن بسبب
محاوله هروب الى ملجا عمليا قريب اصيب
مستوطن حاليا كل المنطقه الجنوبيه الملاجئ
مفتوحه هذه هي التعليمات التي صدرت طبعا
هذا يدلل على ان هذه الغابات الليله قد
تستمر بشكل او باخر
بالاضافه الى ذلك جرى ايضا رفع حاله
التاهب وسط اسرائيل في تلاميذ في مطار بن
غوريون ايضا هناك بطاريات قبه حديديه
للتحسبا بامكان ان تتطور في هذه المواجهه
وان تصل الصواريخ الى وسط اسرائيل طبعا
لكن صهيب نستطيع ان نتحدث انا وانت عن
نهايه ما يحدث في غطاء غزه وهو وقف اطلاق
النار بواسطه مصريه الامر يبقى معروفا
سلفا السؤال متى يتم ذلك هل هذه جوله
قصيره ام قد تستمر ايامنا هذا لا نستطيع
ان نعرفه في هذه المرحله نعم هذا ما سنبقى
في متابعته اذا وما ستؤول اليه الامور
شكرا لك حتى الان اذا زياد حلبي مدير مكتب
العربيه من الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه
اعود الى السيد الينيسان في القدس
سيد ايلي هل تسمعني
سيد ايلينيسان
نعم
هل تسمعني سيدي
قبل قليل نعم من الكبينات
الاقتصادي في لبنان
حزب الله نقل رسائل عن طريق وسطاء انهم
يريدون ان يبقوا خارج الصوره في الحرب
وهذه الاقوال مع الرساله التي نقلتها
منظمه حزب الله هي كانت العنصر الهام في
اتخاذ القرارات في الكابينات ولكن
[موسيقى]
لتهيئه المكان لصلاه الفجر عندما ياتوا
ياتوا المصلون للصلاه لصلاه الفجر ولكن
450 عنصر الذين صغوا
حماس بان هناك تهديد على على مكانه الحرم
القتلى الشريف هم رفضوا الانصياع ورفضوا
مغادره المكان ولذلك الشرطه اضطرت الى
القيام بما قامت به فلذلك ولكن سيد اليه
بغض النظر عن تفسيرات الوضع في الحرم
القدسي الشريف ولكن اسالك كذلك ما سالته
للدكتور مخيمر
ما علاقه الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل مع
هذه الموجه الجديده من التصعيد
بقول لك بصراحه تفضل
يومين حركه حماس اطلقت صواريخ واسرائيل لم
ترد يوم امس في الليل اطلقت 16
صاروخا باتجاه اسرائيل واسرائيل لم ترد
بمعنى ان اسرائيل حاولت تهدئه الخواطر
وتهدئه الاوضاع لا لا علاقه بالاوضاع
الداخليه صحيح ان هناك كانت مظاهرات داخل
اسرائيل في الشوارع وانا اؤكد لك انها يوم
السبت هذا السبت ستستمر المظاهرات ولكن
ولكن انت سمعت ايضا سمعت ايضا رئيس رئيس
المعارضه وسمعت وزير الدفاع السابق الذي
هو معارضه ايضا
بالحرف الاول ان عندما يكون طوارئ في
اسرائيل لا يوجد معارضه ولا يوجد الائتلاف
ونحن صفا الى صف نحمل مع الحكومه
الداخليه الحاليه في اسرائيل على المجهود
العسكري الاسرائيلي دكتور مخيمر اذا كنت
تسمعنا كيف
ترد على على ما قاله
السيد ايلي نيسان هل طيب دكتور مخيم ليس
معنا اذا الان ولكن ينضم الينا كذلك في
هذه التغطيه دكتور مصري استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه دكتور مئير
الملاحظ كما قال مراسلنا قبل قليل اسرائيل
قصفت من الشمال ولكنها ترد من الجنوب
لماذا
شكرا لكم على الاستضافه استاذ صهيب تحياتي
لك وللصديق الي نيسان ولجميع من يشاهدنا
في الواقع نعم تعرضت اسرائيل اليوم الى
جريمه حرب شنعاء وهو اسقاط على الاقل 37
صاروخ على رؤوس المدنيين الاسرائيليين
يهودا وعربا على حد سواء ولو لم تكن بحوده
اسرائيل منظومه القبه الحديديه لستشهد
الاسرائيليين بالمئات اليوم
والتهديد ياتي من لبنان طبعا لبنان منقسم
حول مساله عقارب الساعه ولكن الجماعات
المسلحه تسرح وتمرح على اراضيه في وضح
النهار والحكومه اللبنانيه ليست على علم
على الاطلاق بما يحدث في قلب البلاد
واطرافها ولكن ما حدث اليوم هو حوفقا
للتقارير الاستخباراتيه الاسرائيليه هو
انه هناك ضلوع لعناصر حمساويه في داخل
اللبناني خرجت المعسكرات اللاجئين التي هي
وفق الاتفاق القاهره بالعام 69 والذي هو
سعر حتى اليوم خارج عن نطاق السياده
اللبنانيه وهذه الصواري من هناك وبالتالي
اسرائيل سوف ترد وترد داخل القطاع ولكن
هذه مساله ولكني لا استبعد ان يكون هناك
كذلك ردا في الجنوب اللبناني وانا استمعت
الى تصريح رئيس الحكومه وكذلك تغريده وزير
الدفاع الذي قال بانه اسرائيل قادره على
ان تحارب على اكثر من جبهه وهذه اشاره الى
انه من الممكن ان تكون كذلك دكتور منير هل
اسرائيل قادره على ان تجابه في الداخل
الازمه الداخليه الحاليه والانقسام الشديد
المظاهرات والصراع ما بين القوى اليمينيه
واليسار وكذلك تواجه على المستوى الخارجي
في نفس الوقت
في ذلك انا اعتقد انه لا علاقه بين هذا
وذاك اولا لا علاقه بين
المشكله الامنيه والتي تواجهها اسرائيل من
هذه الانتهاكات من
واللون السياسي للحكومه حيث ان اسرائيل
تعرضت لاكثر من ذلك في العام الفائت في
شهر رمضان المبارك في ظل حكومه ما سمي
انذاك بحكومه التغيير برئاسه وبمشاركه
الاخوان المسلمين السيد منصور لا علاقه
بين الحكومه الحاليه التي نعم يا حكومه
يمينيه تحتوي على العناصر متطرفه وانا من
الذين يت ضدها ولكن ولكن لا علاقه بين هذا
وذاك وانا يعني لا اخفي لك وللمشاهدين
بانه عليك وعلى المشاهدين عفوا بانه ما
يحدث هو يوحد الصف الاسرائيلي ونحن راينا
وانا قرات تغريده
للسيد لبيد رئيس المعارضه والرجل الثاني
في المعارضه كذلك كوزير الدفاع السابق بني
جانس وكلاهما قال انه يجب ان توضع
المشاكل او الانقسامات السياسيه جانبا
والعمل على وحده الصف في مواجهه الارهاب
وصلت الفكره دكتور ماهر ارجو ان تبقى معي
يجهز معنا الان اذا من جديد دكتور مخيمر
ابو سعده من قطاع غزه دكتور مخيمر اهلا بك
معنا من جديد
اهلا وسهلا قبل قليل السيد الي نيسان كان
يتحدث على انه حركه حماس هي التي تريد ان
تجر اسرائيل الى مواجهه مفتوحه من خلال
اطلاقها عده مرات صواريخ على اسرائيل
واسرائيل كما قال يعني انه ضبطت نفسها ولم
ترد على هذا الى اليوم يعني حتى تم اطلاق
هذا الكم من الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان هل
حقا حماس تريد جر اسرائيل الى مواجهه
مفتوحه وهي لا تريد
يعني عزيزي هو يعني
يتناسى او يحاول ان يتجاهل ان المشكله
الاساسيه في هي في الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المستمر على الارض الفلسطينيه منذ 55 عاما
يحاول ان يتجاهل ان المشكله هي من خلال
التوسع الاستيطاني وقتل الفلسطينيين
اليومي دعني اشير الى انه اكثر من 90
فلسوا على يد القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
منذ بدايه هذا العام 2023 بمعدل فلسطيني
كل يوم يقتل اضافه الى الاعتداء غير
المبرر على المصلين في المسجد الاقصى الان
يعني يبدو ان السيد يريد يعني ان يذهب الى
يعني
الشيء الاسهل وهو يعني ادانه حماس او
تحميل حماس المسؤوليه الصواريخ التي اطلقت
من قطاع غزه وهذا ليس دفاعا عن حماس هي
كانت ردا على الاعتداء الاسرائيلي على
المصلين على النساء والاطفال والشيوخ في
باحات المسجد الاقصى لانه في نهايه الامر
يعني المقاومه الفلسطينيه والشعب
الفلسطيني يعتبر ان المسجد الاقصى وهو
اولى القبلتين وثالث الحرمين الشريفين هو
خط احمر لا يمكن تجاوزه لا يمكن السكوت
على هذه الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه ومحاوله
اسرائيل المتكرره بتغيير الواقع القانوني
والتاريخي للمسجد الاقصى يعني هذا هذا
مكان عباده للمسلمين وحسب كل الوثائق
التاريخيه منذ ايام الانتداب البريطاني
وحتى هذا اليوم تفيد بانه هذا منطقه يعني
خاصه بالمسلمين وهنا ك محاولات يهوديه
وخاصه خلال فتره هذا العيد لذبح القرابين
في ساحات الاقصى هذا هو هذه هي المشكله
وهذا هو السبب الذي ادى الى التصعيد
الحالي طيب ولكن دكتور مخيمر اسمح لي
اسالك سؤالا طرحته قبل قليل على
ضيفي ايضا دكتور مئير لماذا اسرائيل تقصف
من الشمال وهي ترد من الجنوب
او بالاحرف بدات ردها من الجنوب
بسبب القذائف التي اطلقت من قطاع غزه خلال
اليومين الماضيين علما ان اسرائيل ردت ردت
بشكل
محدود في اليومين الماضيين ولكن يبدو كذلك
انه حسب المعلومات الامنيه الاسرائيليه ان
حماس او جهات مقربه من حماس هي من يقف
وراء اطلاق القذائف الصاروخيه من لبنان
على منطقه شمال اسرائيل علما بان حماس لم
تعلن مسؤوليتها عن هذه الصواريخ وحماس
دائما تبارك وتعلن تاييدها لايات
ضد اسرائيل باعتبار انه هذا رد طبيعي كما
تعتبره على جرائم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بحق
الفلسطيني ربما ان اسرائيل لا تريد
مواجهه كبيره لهذا لم ترد حتى الان او لم
تقصف جنوب لبنان على الاقل
انه قد لا تريد ان تذهب الى مواجهه مع حزب
الله انا اعتبار ان امكانيات وقدرات حزب
الله العسكريه هي افضل بكثير من امكانيات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه هذا اولا
وثانيا يعني يبدو انه الذهاب الى يعني حرب
مع لبنان وحزب الله يعني قد يعني
تؤدي الى استنكار دولي واسع ضد اسرائيل
ولكن هذا لا يعني ان اسرائيل لن ترد او ان
اسرائيل لن تذهب باتجاه عمل الانتقامي في
لبنان او في سوريا ولذلك يعني هي اختارت
ان تضرب في غزه اولا ولكن قد يكون هناك رد
اسرائيلي ضد لبنان او ضد سوريا خلال
الايام القادمه لانه كما قال وزير الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان اسرائيل ستحدد مكان وزمان
الرد الاسرائيلي ولذلك قد يكون هناك رد
قادم خلال الايام القادمه ضد لبنان او ضد
حزب الله
سيد الي نيسان في القد س تعلم نحن في شهر
رمضان المبارك وهو يحظى بقدسيه لدى
المسلمين
والغزيون الان اذا عاشوا ليله يعني من
الخوف والترقب وهم الان بانتظار وقت
السحور هل يمكن ان يتسحروا الان
قد توقف القصف ام هناك جولات اخرى برايك
انا هعرض لك عدد السؤال ولكن انا اقول
لدكتور مخيمر عده نقاط من مين احتلت
اسرائيل الضفه الغربيه هل احتلت الضفه
الغربيه من الشعب الفلسطيني اين كان يلعب
الشعب الفلسطيني عام 67 اسرائيل احتلت
الضفه الغربيه من المملكه الاردنيه وليس
من الدوله الفلسطينية لماذا لماذا اردن لن
اقيم الدوله
[ضحك]
67 خلينا في الليله الليله هل هل يمكن
للغذيين ان يناموا الان او يتصحروا
هانيئين برايك
سؤال ولكن هو يتحدث عن مقتل الفلسطينيين
هل ام فلسطينيين ابرياء الذين ليس لهم اي
ضلع بالارهاب
كيف يمكن ان تقعد اسرائيل مكتوفه الايدي
عندما يقتل الشباب والنساء والاشخاص في
شوارع تل ابيب وشوارع
في شوارع العاد وغيرها ثم اقول
اسرائيل اسرائيل تواصل ضربات منظمه حزب
الله
منظمه حماس في الوقت الحاضر انا لا اعلم
انا قلت ان جهاز الامن العام جهاز الجيش
قبل التوصيات الحكومه قبل التوصيات لجهاز
الامن وهي تستهدف ايضا المواقع حركه حماس
في لبنان مع العلم ان كما قلت في بدايه
كلامي حركه حركه منظمه حزب الله قالت داخل
مستطاع بواسطه البسطاء انها هي تريد ان
تكون خارج اللعبه في هذه المسرح
اذا هم في السحور او لا هذا يتعلق فقط في
حركه حماس اذا حركه حماس واصلت اطلاق
الصواريخ وسمعت قبل قليل
حلبي اذا هم يريدون اطلاق الصواريخ ايضا
باتجاه مركز دوله اسرائيل مركز اسرائيل
وبالقرب التل ابيب طبعا هذا الامر يؤدي
الى تفاقم الاوضاع ولذلك وصلت الفكره يعني
نفس الذي قالته المصادر الاسرائيليه بان
الرد الاسرائيلي يتوقف على رد الفصائل
الفلسطينيه دكتور مخيمر ابو سعده في غزه
لك حق الرد ايضا وهل برايك حماس والفصائل
ستصعد اكثر هذه الليله
ساقول بشكل مختصر يعني ردا على ما قاله
سواء احتلت اسرائيل الضفه الغربيه والقدس
من الاردن او احتلتها من طرف اخر في نهايه
الامر هناك شعب فلسطيني تعداده 14 مليون
نسمه سبعه منهم سبعه مليون منهم يعيشون في
الضغط الغربي وغزه والقدس وداخل اسرائيل
ولذلك بغض النظر عن من كان مسؤولا على
الدرس الغربي عندما احتلت اسرائيل هذه
الارض هناك شعب فلسطيني يستحق الحياه
يستحق الدوله يستحق ان يعيش بحريه وكرامه
دون احتلال ودون استيطان ودون عنف ودعنه
يشير الى نقطه اخرى انه من ضمن التسعين
فلسطينيين الذين قتلوا من ببدايه هذا
العام 17 طفلا دون سن 18 اضافه الى سيده
مسنه فلسطينيه ولذلك ليس كل من تم
استهدافهم هم نشطاء في المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اما في نهايه الامر يعني فيما
يخص هذا التصعيد الامر يتوقف على اسرائيل
اذا ارادت بعتقد اسرائيل توسيع هذا
العدوان على قطاع غزه قد تذهب الامور الى
الى يعني تصعيد اكبر من خلال رد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ولكن يبدو يعني ان رسائل
الوسطاء الذين يعني يحاولوا احتواء الموقف
الان انه تشير الى انه هذا التصعيد يعني
لا اسرائيل ارادت فقط
يعني ترضي الجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه
وتسكت المعارضه الاسرائيليه من خلال شن
هذا العدوان على قطاع غزه وان اسرائيل
ليست معنيه بالذهاب الى تصعيد مع القطاع
دعني اشير لك انه الوقت في الوقت الحالي
الاوضاع هادئه نسبيا الان بعد عمليات
القذف التي حصلت قبل حوالي ساعتين ولذلك
يبدو يبدو ان الامور تتجه الى يعني تخفيض
حده العنف خلال الساعات القادمه شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور مخيمر ابو سعده استاذ
العلوم السياسيه كنت معنا من قطاع غزه
دكتور مئر مصري اعود اليك هل يعني برايك
اسرائيل
فعلا استجابت للوساطات المصريه او
الامريكيه كذلك
من اجل ان يكون الرد عند هذا الحد فقط
اعتقد انه من المبكر ان نحكم على نجاحها
وعدم نجاح هذه الوصفات وجديه هذه الوسطات
ولكن
لا شك في انه اسرائيل وردا على ما قاله
السيد مخيمر يعني اي دوله في العالم
لا يكون لها رده فعل بعد ان تسقط عليها
عشرات الصواريخ والخزائف في مناطق ماهوله
بالسكان يعني حتى حتى حتى لا تتغير قواعد
الاشتباك انا اعتقد انه لا يجب ان تكون
هناك حد ادنى من من الرد وبالتالي انا
اعتقد بانه ما يحدث اليوم هو شيء متوقع
وانا اعتقد انه اي شخص كان من الممكن ان
يتوقع ان يتوقع ذلك الذي يقول لك انه
الاحتلال هو السبب اي احتيال هو سبب كيف
احتيال هو السبب ما علاقه الاحتلال بين
هلالين بهذا النهج وبهذا المسلك وان كان
هذا صحيحا نحن
المسيحيين يدخلون يتعدون على على الشرطه
يحاولون ادخال السلاح الابيض وزجاجات
الحارقه داخل الكنائس او مسلمين علمانيين
او ليبراليين هؤلاء اصليين لا علاقه لهم
على الاطلاق
السياق السياسي كما انه اسرائيل في ظل
حكومات حزب العمل تعرضت لابشع العمليات
الارهابيه من قبل حماس والجهاد وجبه
الشعبيه وجبه الديمقراطيه وتنظيم فتح وانا
كعض لجنه المركزيه بعمل اقول لك ان هؤلاء
هم الذين دمروا حزب بحزب العمل وافقدون
السلطه حيث انه نحن في ظل العمليه السلميه
والانسحاب الاسرائيلي من المنطقه التي
اصبحت فيما بعد مناطق حكم ذاتي كنا نتعرض
لابش على عمليه ارهابيه عشرات الاس كانوا
يقتلون كل يوم من قبل حماس هؤلاء غير
معنيون على الاطلاق بمساله الحل السلمي او
مساله الوصول الى حاله الدولتين
او اداره العربيه او السعوديه
هم فقط اذرع للنظام الايرانيه هناك توجه
معين اشعار النيران في كل مكان
انه من المبكر الان الحكم على اذا كانت
اسرائيل قد استجابت للوساطه من عدمها متى
يمكن الحكم
هو كل شيء هو حسب هذا توقف على رده فعل
الطرف الاخر هل غدا سوف نستيقظ على اطلاق
صواريخ من جديد من حماس او عناصر اخرى غير
حماس من الجنوب اللبناني من قطاع غزه لا
نعرف ولكن انا انا استطيع ان اؤكد بانه
اسرائيل غير معنيه بالتصعيد على الاطلاق
وخصوصا حكومات اليمين عكس ما يتصوره البعض
لانه الامير معني يعني حكومه يمنيه وطبعا
يعني شعارات
الانتخابيه كذلك تصريحات
المتعدد المعاديه للفلسطينيين بشكل كبير
جدا يعني اذا كانت تنبئ بتصعيد اكبر دكتور
ام لا
لا كريم هو عنوان الحكومه فيما يتعلق
بالمسائل الامنيه الكبرى ودخول وعدم دخول
خاصه السيد غير معني على الاطلاق باحتواء
حركه حماس وبعوده الشرايات الفلسطينيه الى
قطاع غزه بالعكس
بالفعل يجب ان لا نتسرع في الحكم على
انتهاء الغارات الاسرائيليه لانها تجددت
الان
على قطاع غزه اعذرني فقط دكتور اذكر بهذا
الخبر العاجل ورد للتو اذا نقلا عن مراسل
العربيه يقول ان الغارات قد تجددت على
قطاع غزه
ارجو ان تبقى معي اذهب الى غزه معنا من
هناك طلال عوكل الكاتب السياسي استاذ طلال
اهلا بك هل بوسعك بدايه ان تؤكد اذا كانت
الغارات قد تجددت الان في غزه
يعني متقطعه ولم يكن من
الاعتقاد بانها بعد ساعه او ساعه ونصف لكن
هي تتجه نحو التهدئه لماذا ليس فقط لان
الوسطاء تدخلوا بقوه او لان اسرائيل اصلا
هي السبب في هذا التصعيد ابتداء من المسجد
الاقصى ليلتين
متتاليتين ارهاب شديد امام العالم
العالم كله اذان ما تقوم باسرائيل وانما
لانه
اسرائيل في الوضع الراهن يكذب هذا الضيف
اسرائيل
الردع لديها تاكل كثيرا وهي تخشى من ان
تدخل في
اشتباك مع عده جبهات رغم انهم يعلنون كل
ذلك
وكل الوقت ولكن اتضح ان اسرائيل تخشى من
ان تدخل في حرب حقيقيه مع لبنان ومع غزه
وحتى مع غزه لوحدها
قبل دفعه ايام قال بانه يمكن لاسرائيل
الان ترفع عدد التصاريح الممنوحه للامال
الى خمسين الف ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان
اسرائيل تريد ان تتجنب الصدام مع غزه
الوضع الداخلي الاسرائيلي
مهزوم جدا جدا
وبالتالي هذه الحكومه
ضعيفه رغم طبيعتها الفاشيه العنصريه لكنها
ضعيفه الجيش يتفكك اجهزه الامن الشرطه اذا
نحن امام جوله فقط الجوله لن تتجاوز ال 24
ساعه والا
لكانت الصواريخ انها اسرائيل من قطاع غزه
حتى الان ردود الفصائل في غزه محدود جدا
هنا سؤال كذلك استاذ طلال الفصائل
الفلسطينيه
بدورها يعني هي اطلقت عددا من الصواريخ
فقط على مستوطنات الغلاف غلاف قطاع غزه
كيف يفهم هذا ايضا
الجانب الاول هو احتراما
التدخلات والوساطات خصوصا المصريه
والاردنيه والقطريه بالتاكيد التي تدخل
على الخط كل الوقت الثانيه هي جزء من
حسابات سياسيه
المقاومه هنا لا ترغب في ان تلفت الانظار
عن الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل بينما هذه
الازمه عمليا تتعمق يوم بعد يوم ويتفسخ
معها المجتمع ويبدو ان اسرائيل في اضعف
حالاتها ولذلك
المقاومه اجرت حساباتي على اساس ان تتجنب
الصدام من قطاع غزه حتى لا يتوحد
الاسرائيليون وبالتالي هذا حساب منطقي
حساب حكيم بالمعنى السياسي بين الوقت
والاخر كانت تصدر رسائل لاسرائيل ولكن
يعني مع ان التصعيد في القدس والمسجد
الاقصى كان مرتفعا وادى الى اندلاع كيف
القدس عام 2021
لكنه هذه المره لم يحرك المقاومه في غزه
لاسباب تتعلق بالحسابات السياسيه وهذه
الحسابات صحيحه نعم
دكتور مصري
كيف ترد على ما قاله الاستاذ طلال انه
اسرائيل الان ضعيفه من الداخل
وهي بالتالي لا تستطيع ان تجابه على عده
جبهات
ومن مصلحتها ان تكون هناك
يكون هناك احتواء لهذه الجوله الجديده من
التصعيد
يعني شوف انا بغض النظر عما قيل انا اريد
ان اقول هو تقييم خاطئ للموقف وبالتالي من
يبني تصرفاته على تقييم خاطئ انا اعتقد
بانه في النهايه المطاف لن يخدم مصلحه
شعبي الازف الشديد هناك من يعني يريد من
خلال الكلام المعلب والاتهامات الحاضره
دائما في كل مناسبه ان يدين اسرائيل الهدف
هو ادانه اسرائيل الهدف يجب ان يكون حل
المشاكل الخروج من الازمه هذا هو يكون
الهدف وليس مجرد الادانه ولكن دكتور وائل
هو تحدث عن وقائع شهدت ادانات عربيه
ودوليه يعني المصلون المعتكفون في المسجد
الاقصى يعني من شباب واطفال وشيوخ كذلك
جرى الاعتداء عليهم من قبل الجنود الجنود
الاسرائيليين هو يعني انا اريد ان اسال
يعني هل هل الاعتكاف لا يكون الا
بالزجاجات الحارقه الا الا بادخال سلاح
ابيض الى المسجد الاقصى
الادخاله الثلاجات والمؤن والتمويل للبقاء
ايام داخل هؤلاء يريدون تنظيم اعتصام داخل
المسجد لا علاقه بين هذا
وبالاعتكاف واصوله على الاطلاق وليس هناك
شيوخ والنساء كما ذكر وهؤلاء شباب
وعدد محدود للغايه بالنسبه للاعداد
الكبيره التي اتت من من الضفه والمناطق
الحكم الذاتي حيث انه تصاريح هذه المره
كانت اغلطتها اسرائيل بوفره شديده وفقا
لما طلبته السلطه
نعود الى النقطه الاولى فعليا يعني في
الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل يعني كان هناك
تحذير من الرئيس الاسرائيلي من احتماليه
وجود حرب اهليه كان هناك تحذيرات من عدم
تنفيذ قطاعات عسكريه وامنيه للاوامر
الا ينبئ هذا بالفعل على ان هناك ازمه
حقيقيه وعميقه داخل اسرائيل تجعلها حذره
في ان تذهب باتجاه تصعيد كبير
مع احترامي للرئيس للرئيس لرئيس اسرائيل
اربعه اشهر ونصف من المظاهرات الضخمه غير
المسبوقه في تاريخ اسرائيل ضباط اشهر ونصف
ولم تسقط قطره دم واحده واحده لم يجرح
شخص واحد وبالتالي الذي تحدث عن حرب اهليه
هو ربما يبالغ
وهذه النقطه نقطه ثانيه اي انشقاق داخل
الجيش واي تفكك للجيش ولا الاجهزه الامنيه
كلما حصل هو انه عدد محدود للغايه من
الضباط الاحتياط امتنعوا مره واحده عن
تنفيذ مهام اختياريه وعدد اخر من الضبابه
شاركوا في المظاهرات وعدد محدود بعد وبزين
المدني بعضا حصلوا على موافقه من قياداتهم
ومن القضاء العسكري اذا الامور اولا عدد
محدود للغايه وكل الامور
حدثت او وقعت في اثاره الشرعيه انت لازم
يتحدث عن خوف من حرب اهليه او تفكك للبنى
الجيش في اسرائيل اعتقد ان هناك مبالغه
كبيره ان اقول اولا انني ااسف لا لا
لسقوط ضحايا من من عند المدنيين
الفلسطينيين وانا اريد ان اقول انه انا
اخشى على المدنيين الفلسطينيين في قطاع
غزه اكثر على المدنيين لانه جيش يحمينا
لكن هم للاسف الشديد ليس هناك من يحميهم
وبالعكس هم يحاولون الى دروع بشريه ولكن
جوهر الموضوع هو انه حركه حماس اليوم ضاقت
بها قطاع غزه وهي تحاول ان تحل نفسها في
المشهد المقدسي والمشهد داخل
نعم
اخذ وجهه نظر لان وقتي وقتي ينتهي ويجب ان
حق الرق الرب الى نعم دكتور وصلت فكرتك
استاذ طلال عوكل هل تسمعني
نعم استمعت الى ما قاله الدكتور مئر وتحدث
عن الاعتكاف في المسجد الاقصى وهو يتحدث
على انه
هؤلاء ليسوا معتكفين بل كانوا يعدون كما
قال يعني انه كانوا يحملون اسلحه بيضاء
ومؤن هناك في المسجد الاقصى مرضك
اللي بده يكذب ويدافع بطريقه شوي يعني
يرحم المستمعين والمشاهدين ما هو
الذي جرى في المسجد الاقصى كان امام
وسائل الاعلام
الجيش يدخل
ويضرب بالهراوات النساء والشباب والاطفال
المعتكفون ويعتقل
شاب وامراه
ويبقي منهم في قيد التحقيق حوالي اربعين
والبقيه يبعدهم عن المسجد الاقصى نتنياهو
بعظمه لسانه قال ان هؤلاء المعتكفين هم
نواصل بمتطرفه متطرفه ماذا ماذا فعلوا
وكيف قاوموا الجيش الاسرائيلي الا
باجسادهم هذه كذبه تفضحها وسائل الاعلام
ويتبعها ردود الفعل العلمي
اذا يعني اذا كانت اسرائيل حتى نفهم ما
يحصل اذا كانت اسرائيل لا تسعى الى مواجهه
كبيره او لا تسعى الى حرب مفتوحه في هذه
المرحله
في اي اطار يوضع التصعيد
التصعيد اولا ليس تكتيكيا بالمعنى القريب
اسرائيل تريد ان تفرض
التقسيم الزماني والمكاني على المسجد
الاقصى وخلال الاعياد الاسرائيليه التي
بدات يوم الثلاثاء وتمتد لاسبوع كان مطلوب
افراغ المسجد الاقصى من المعتكفين حتى
يتسنى دخول عشرات او مئات اليهود لاداء
صلواتهم وذبح القرابين في المسجد الاقصى
في ظل غياب فلسطيني كامل عن المسجد الاقصى
اما الشيء الاساسي لانه هذه السياسه سياسه
اصيله لدى هذه الحكومه هذه الحكومه
متطرفه هذه الحكومه عنصريه فاشيه الكل سمع
كل التصريحات سواء
قال لا وجود الشعب الفلسطيني وبالتالي
طلال وصلت الفكره نعم اساسيه
اسمحلي في الدقائق الباقيه من هذه الساعه
ضمن تغطيه العربيه المستمره لتطورات الوضع
في غزه اعود الى غزه لنرصد
وضع هناك الان احمد حرب معنا الصحفي
الفلسطيني من غزه احمد اهلا بك معنا في
تغطيه العربيه
احمد احمد حرب هل تسمعني
طيب
احمد هل انت جاهز معنا للمره الاخيره
طيب احمد يبدو انه
يبدو انه ليس جاهز معنا طيب كما نتابع
معكم اذا مشاهدينا في هذه الصور حتى الان
قبل حوالي ساعتين من الان كانت هناك غارات
اسرائيليه استهدفت
موقعين
عسكريين كما قالت اسرائيل تابعه
لكتائب عز الدين القسام الجناح المسلح
لحركه حماس مراسل العربيه تحدث عن تجدد
الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه قبل
قليل
طيب
كان هناك ايضا تجدد للغارات اذا احمد حرب
معنا الان مباشره من غزه احمد هل تسمعني
الان
اهلا اهلا بك معنا
ما حقيقه تجدد الغارات الاسرائيليه على
القطاع احمد
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه هناك
تضارب في هذه الغارات قبل قليل كان هناك
استهداف كما ذكرت وسائل الاعلام لموقع
عيسى البطران في وسط القطاع عند مدخل مخيم
البريد وسط القطاع وقبل قليل وصل نبا بان
الانفجار الذي حصل او الغاره التي حصلت في
ذات المكان في وسط القطاع عند مكه المخيم
البريد هي لم تكن لهذا الموقع وكانت في
منطقه حتى هذه اللحظه لم يذكر تفاصيل
في سياق هذا او سياق هذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه حتى هذه اللحظه الاجواء
التصعيد مازالت في القطاع قبل قليل كان
هناك يعني
استهدافات متعدده في مناطق مختلفه من
القطاع وايضا استهدفت
الطائرات الحربيه الاستراليه رشاش من
العيار اللي استخدمته والفصائل الفلسطينيه
في اطلاقك باطلاق عدد من الرصاصات باتجاه
المحاديه بالقطع نعم تفضل احمد ارجو ان
تبقى معنا تتفضل بالبقاء معنا هذه الساعه
انتهت ولكن التغطيه مستمره على العربيه
كما نتابع صور مباشره لغزه الهدوء الحذر
هو سيد الموقف بعد سلسله الغارات
الاسرائيليه اذا كما نتابع الان هذه صور
على ما يبدو اذا لتجدد الغارات
الاسرائيليه قبل قليل
اذا هذه هي الصور الاوليه اذا للغارات
الجديده اذا التي تجددت قبل قليل على قطاع
غزه اذا مشاهدينا على العموم كما ذكرت
التغطيه مستمره الان نعود الى الزميل محمد
عثمان يستكمل معكم التطورات اذن الان في
قطاع غزه مع التجدد هذه الغارات والصور
الاوليه التي وردتنا للتو محمد اليك